♪ 50 [INAUDIBLE]
>> Lawrence: UFOS ARE REAL,
AMERICA.
EVERY DAY IT FEELS LIKE ANOTHER
VIDEO OF UNIDENTIFIED FLYING
OBJECT ZIPPING ACROSS THE SKY.
WHY DOES IT SEEM LIKE THE U.S.
MILITARY IS CONCERNED WITH WOKE
AGENDA THAN THE VERY REAL THREAT
OF ALIENS.
MAYBE ALIENS HAVE FRAGILITY.
MY NEXT GUEST FIRED FOR DECRYING
RACISM IN THE MILITARY.
IN NEW BOOK REVOLUTIONING
MATTHEW LOHMEIER CLAIMING
MARXIST IDEOLOGY TOO PREVALENT.
BROUGHT HIS CASE TO CONGRESS
MEETING WITH SEVERAL SENATORS
ABOUT THE ISSUE THIS WEEK.
MATT LOHMEIER JOINS ME NOW.
LIEUTENANT COLONEL THANK YOU FOR
JOINING ME.
WHAT IS YOUR BIG BEEF OF THE
MILITARY.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN THE TYPE OF
MARXISM THAT IS BEING TAUGHT IN
THE MILITARY?
>>
>> LAWRENCE, THANKS FOR HAVING
ME.
MY BIG BEEF, THAT'S THE FIRST
TIME IT'S BEEN PUT THAT WAY.
I LIKE THAT QUESTION.
>> I WILL SAY FIRST I DON'T
SPEAK FOR THE DEFENSE DEPARTMENT
THESE ARE MY PERSONAL VIEWS
ALTHOUGH IT'S CLEAR TO ME I'M
NOT ALONE IN THESE VIEWS.
THE COUNTRY HAS BECOME
INCREASINGLY AWARE OF SOMETHING
OVER THE LAST CUP COUPLE WEEKS
IF NOT OVER THE LAST YEAR IT'S
CRITICAL RACE THEORY.
IT'S THE GRANDCHILD OF CRITICAL
THEORY CREATED BY MARXIST WHO
CAME OVER HERE A CENTURY AGO
FROM GERMANY IN THE FRANKFURT
SCHOOL.
THAT'S THE MARXISM THAT I'M
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFYING IN MY
BOOK AND THAT I HAVE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ON A NUMBER OF
SHOWS RECENTLY.
AND, FORTUNATELY AS I POINTED
OUT, IT'S NOT JUST ME THERE IS A
GROUP THAT I CAME TO KNOW ABOUT
IN THE LAST SEVERAL MONTHS
CALLED STARS STARRS STAND
TOGETHER AGAINST RACISM AND
RADICALISM IN THE SERVICES.
AND WHEREAS JUST A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO THAT GROUP HAS SEVERAL DOZEN
RETIRED ALUMNI FROM ACROSS ALL
OF THE SERVICE ACADEMIES THAT
MEMBERSHIP HAS BOOST TO 1600.
RE CONCERNED RETIRED GENERAL
OFFICERS AND OTHER RETIRED
OFFICERS AND SERVICE MEMBERS AND
OTHER CONCERNED STIPULATES.
SO, IT'S NOT JUST ME THAT'S
CONCERNED ABOUT IT.
IT'S ME, IT'S THEM.
IT'S OTHER PARENTS.
AND OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM AND THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT NOT JUST THE
U.S. MILITARY BUT SEEMS TO BE
ACROSS OUR ENTIRE SOCIETY.
>> Lawrence: SO YOU MET WITH THE
SENATORS TODAY.
DID YOU GET ANY FEEDBACK?
IS THERE GOING TO BE SOME TYPE
OF INVESTIGATION THERE?
>> YEAH, SO I WAS REALLY
GRATEFUL THERE HAVE BEEN A GREAT
DEAL OF CONGRESSMAN AND SENATORS
SHOW WHO HAVE SHOWN INTEREST IN
THESE ISSUES AND SUPPORT FOR ME
AND FOR THE IDEAS THAT I WAS
HOPING TO SHARE WITH THEM AS
WELL.
SO AT THEIR REQUEST, I WAS UP IN
WASHINGTON, D.C. THE PAST
SEVERAL DAYS IN MY PRIVATE
CAPACITY BUT TO TALK ABOUT MY
EXPERIENCES IN THE MILITARY.
SENATOR TOM COTTON FROM ARKANSAS
SPENT A LOT OF TIME WITH ME AND
MY ATTORNEY.
SENATOR TED CRUZ ALSO MET WITH
ME AND CONGRESSMAN MIKE WALTZ
FORMER GREEN ENTER WRAY AND A
ANOTHER OF STAFFERS WHOSE
CONGRESSMAN AND CONGRESSWOMEN
RECENTLY WROTE A LETTER FOR MY
SUPPORT REQUESTING MY
REINSTATEMENT.
A GREAT DEAL OF CONGRESS MEN AND
WOMEN HAVE SHOWN SUPPORT FOR
THIS AND GREAT CONCERN OVER WHAT
IT IS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
HEARING FROM ME BUT NOT JUST
FROM ME BUT FROM OTHERS NOW
ACROSS THE SERVICES.
THEY HAVE HAVE LENT A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT.
THEY ARE LOOKING INTO THIS.
THEY ARE GATHERING DOCUMENTS AT
THE MOMENT TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND
I THINK THAT THE PICTURE IS
BECOMING CLEARER AND CLEARER TO
THEM AND I WON'T PRETEND TO KNOW
WHAT IT IS THEY DUAL WITH THAT
INFORMATION BUT I KNOW THEY ARE
VERY CONCERNED.
>> Lawrence: WE ARE GOING TO
KEEP FOLLOWING THAT BUT NOW THE
REAL QUESTION, LIEUTENANT
COLONEL, NOW, YOU ARE A PART OF
SPACE FORCE.
WHERE ARE THESE UFOS?
DO THEY EXIST?
ARE THEY REAL?
WHAT CAN YOU TELL US?
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE REALLY
WANT TO KNOW.
>> HEY, THAT'S A FUN QUESTION.
I WAS ON TUCKER SEVERAL DAYS
AGO.
HE ASKED ME THE SAME QUESTION.
HE WAS HOPING FOR A REALLY JUICY
SPACE FORCE STORY THAT I MIGHT
HAVE FOR HIM AND I TOLD HIM,
LOOK, IF I KNEW SOMETHING
RELATED TO MY JOB ABOUT THAT I
PROBABLY WOULDN'T TELL YOU BUT I
HAVE DONE MY OWN EXPERIENCE IN
HIGH SCHOOL IN THE MOUNTAINS OF
TUCSON AND, IN FACT, SAW
SOMETHING THAT I CAN ONLY
DESCRIBE AS A UFO AND I WASN'T
ALONE.
THERE WAS SOMEONE ELSE WITH ME
LATE AT NIGHT WHEN WE SAW IT.
AND IT WAS VERY UNIQUE
EXPERIENCE.
I CAN'T DESCRIBE IT YOU CAN GO
LISTEN TO WHAT I SAID ON TUCKER
ABOUT IT.
BUT, CLEARLY, THEY ARE REAL.
WHATEVER THEY ARE.
WHETHER, YOU KNOW, AND THERE IS
A LOT OF PEOPLE SPECULATING
ABOUT WHAT THAT IS AND I WON'T.
BUT, YEAH, THAT'S SOMETHING
WORTH LOOKING INTO.
>> Lawrence: SHOULD WOULD HE BE
CONCERNED AS AMERICANS?
I DON'T WANT YOU TO VIOLATE YOUR
POSITION BUT, HELL, I THINK THIS
MAY UNIFY US IF WE REALIZE THE
ALIENS ARE GOING TO COME FOR ALL
OF US THEY DON'T CARE WHAT SHADE
OF COLOR WE ARE.
>> WELL, THERE ARE MANY ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
UNIFY AROUND.
ONE OF THE THINGS, IN FACT,
GOING BACK TO THE TOPIC WE
INITIALLY BROUGHT UP, WHICH IS
CRITICAL RACE THEORY, IT'S MY
CONTENTION THAT MARXIST IDEOLOGY
IS NOT A PARTISAN POLITICAL
ISSUE.
BECAUSE IT'S ANTITHETICAL TO
AMERICA'S FOUNDING VALUES AND
PHILOSOPHY, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT PROVIDES US AN OPPORTUNITY
TO UNITE AND SHOW KIND OF, YOU
KNOW, IF WE ARE TALKING POLITICS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT FOR AMERICA'S
FOUNDING VALUES IN THE FACE OF
THE ONSLAUGHT OF MARXIST
IDEOLOGY.
WE FOUGHT THE COLD WAR OVER THE
SPREAD AND CONTAIN THE SPREAD OF
MARXIST COMMUNIST IDEOLOGY IN
THE WORLD AND SPENT A GREAT DEAL
OF TREASURES BLOOD AND IRON IN
THE PAST CENTURY DOING THAT I
WOULD HATE TO THINK AND, IN
FACT, OTHER SERVICE MEMBERS WHO
HAVE WRITTEN ME LETTERS WOULD
HATE TO THINK SOME OF THEIR
LOVED ONES, IN FACT, WENT TO WAR
OVER THESE VERY ISSUES AND NOW
WE ARE NOT ALLOWED TO SPEAK UP
ABOUT IT WHEN WE SEE IT LARYNX
.>> Lawrence: IT'S